en euros ou en france est le plus gros
budget de l'histoire du cinéma français
45 millions d'euros dont plus de 300
millions de francs astérix et obélix
mission cléopâtre la super production va
défaire les demain assure plus de 900
écrans un plus gros chiffre là encore
jamais atteint maître d'oeuvre alain
chabat scénariste réalisateur et césar
l'empereur réaction après une
avant-première marie-jo jouant dominique
bonnet envers tous concourir leurs *
s'ennuie pas un instant
en super g j'ai adoré alain chabat
semble avoir découvert le secret de la
potion magique un scénario de gaz man
confirmé depardieu clavier des valeurs
gauloise évidente
une bande de copains rencontrés à la
télé et un très joli nez celui de la
bellucci mêlée construira les plus
magnifiques des palettes ajouté
l'insolence dyslexiques de jamel le tout
lié par 45 millions d'euros budget
record du cinéma français pour un
scénariste réalisateur qui avoue lettres
empereur en plus je m'occupe de la
description des pop corn le 30 janvier
dans les salles vous pourrez me croiser
je vous servirai les popcorns oui c'est
une volonté de tout contrôler ses
mouvements de magnac jusqu'à nouvel
ordre aux césars se sont pas les romains
qui ont construit les pyramides
le truc point de vue là je voulais jouer
comme ça j'avais plus j'aime bien ce
côté très prétentieux très mégalo très
je me la raconte et un moment du 10 mai
mais ce que chabat oublie de dire
moi j'ai fait césar parce qu'en fait
c'est mika bellucci peach up autre
aventure action comédie est un enjeu
fallait à construire en trois mois
prenant fin jours de plus
pari réussi dans le film comme sur le
tournage à ouarzazate au maroc
l'esprit de la bd de goscinny et
d'uderzo et sont mises en valeur par
quelques clins d'oeil jubilatoire les
hackers heureux ça se sent dans le film
ambiance de tournage mortels donc
forcément fils mortels le premier opus
de feu diby avait réuni 9 millions de
spectateurs
celui de chabat promet de rassembler un
nombre encore plus pharaonique sortie
donc demain sport